We are taking your phone calls at six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty.
Let me pick up on our caller from the five
five nine areaCode who's calling today from
555 nine.
Hi, David, this is John.
Hey, John, what's up?
Hey.
So I was wondering, what do you think the
likelihood of the next president, either Democratic
or Republican, you know, whoever they may
be with, that they would create some sort
of federal agency to oversee police investigations
into police violence and misconduct like that?
And what do you think the effectiveness of
such a agency could be?
So I don't know if we need a federal agency
to oversee police.
I think it would be really tough to get that
done with police unions being as strong as
they are in the next segment.
I am going to give my prescription for dealing
with police violence and I'm going to talk
about databases of sorts.
I think that we need two things and I won't
fully go into them because I'm going to do
this next segment.
Number one, there should be a national database
of bad actors in police departments because
right now it is too easy.
I'm not saying it's easy, but it is too easy
for a police officer to make a deal to leave
a department because of wrongdoing or complaints.
But it's done in a way where there's no place
that future police departments can see this
officers history and they end up rehiring
a problem officer.
And the vast majority of police officers are
not the problem.
The small percentage there are often are repeat
offenders.
So by just eliminating a few of these bad
actors, you would dramatically reduce the
number of bad acts, so to speak.
So you establish a database of police officer
complaints and you require both that a police
department has to report to the database and
a new hiring police department must check
the database so that nobody can get away with
saying we just didn't know.
So that's one thing.
The other thing is, I think that we do need
a review system for police shootings and use
of force incidents that includes civilians,
where in many cases these things are reviewed
essentially internally, internally by police,
sometimes in concert with, you know, the d.a.'s
office in certain situations.
I don't think that that's cutting it.
I think we definitely need accountability
to civilians as well.
So those are a couple of the things I think
we need to do.
I think a federal agency to do the reviewing
is going to be a tough sell.
Yeah, I was thinking that being like implicating
such a system would probably, if anything,
does cause a lot of backlash and you know
that attention to the police union and stuff
like that.
But I had one other quick question.
Yeah.
About Trump and his Twitter account there
is trying to push for the new restrictions
on them, silencing conservative voices and
whenever making it easier to not get blocked,
you know, to be conservative or whatever.
Right.
So is that in order to helps stop Twitter
from blocking him the day he's no longer president?
I don't think that he's thinking ahead in
that way whatsoever.
I think that these are basically politically
partizan things that Trump believes now will
benefit his side.
I don't think he's saying I'm going to do
this so that Twitter doesn't block me the
day I'm out.
I just don't think he's thinking about that.
I honestly, I don't.
I really don't.
Well, maybe he's just incapable of looking
that far forward.
But one of the reasons why.
All right.
Thank you, my friend.
Appreciate the phone call.
Great to hear from you.